hello everyone today um we have a 2014
uh honda crv um we need to add a key to
this
car okay and i'll show you the original
one
it looks all messed up sometimes the
buttons work sometimes doesn't work
okay so we have a next one
um this is the new one we just cut okay
we have to program this key to this
car look when i put in the ignition let
me show you guys
let me just leave this all the way here
there's a new one as you see okay
i'm gonna put in the ignition
okay i turn the ignition on and you will
see that red light
i'm sorry um the green light blinking on
there you see that
that's indicating the um immobilizer is
not recognizing the key
because it's not registered so um i'm
gonna take this key out
because since we're gonna add a new key
just adding a key not all keys lost
so um we need to have the ignition over
the working key
all right so let's see let's go ahead
with this i'm going to use the im608
and i'll go to immobilizer section i
actually done a lot of these cars before
but never had a chance to take a video
i'm gonna go on
audubon see if it catches it
okay so let's do manual selection
and we have a crv here we go
and it's a blade key
okay and um
let's see the relevant information like
always i do to make sure we have the
right key
um not this one not this one not this
one
not this one but it's supposed to be one
of those keys all right so
um let's go to um
immobilizer honda okay
all right that's connected ignition is
on
right nice trying to configure the um
immobilizer system
to see what kind of immobilizer um
it's in the car
yep it's a fourth generation immobilizer
that's fine
okay so um now
so um as you see we have a whole bunch
of different on options in here
and uh this computer is actually this
m608 is really really good with um
honda cars honda's acura is um
it's really good you can just do so many
things with it i'm gonna go to key
option we're gonna do add key
insert the register key and turn the
ignition on
we did that
turn edition off within 15 seconds it is
off
turning on using a register key against
17 seconds
okay we're doing that turning off 15
seconds
i did that insert the new key and turn
the ignition on
this one okay that's the new one let's
put it in here
i just did that turn ignition on
technician off
okay turn it back on again set it off
again
okay turn it back on again
that's how honda does it guys i'm always
you got to go on and off on and off
cycles um
multiple times did the immobilizer lamp
go out let's check it out
yes you don't see that green light
anymore in there blinking the green um
green or key light is not blinking no
more so let's head
in here yes it did go away turn the
ignition off
turn the edition back on
current number of keys is four so we
successfully have um
added this key let's press ok see all
right so we should be done
now let's check the key guys first i'm
going to take the off let's hear
them all first
yep it's working let's try to start the
car
[Music]
okay i need to break
okay
oh i think this car was changing the
starter actually
that's why i'm gonna try with the
original key but this key is registered
this car right now
i think they were turning started with
this
yeah it's they have a problem with their
starters so they're gonna do something
about that okay
but the key is registered to the car
right now i don't have no immobilizer
light on
and everything is working on the key
guys thank you for so well
thank you so much for watching because
i'll see you guys in the next one
thank you